[Music]
new at six tonight we're going on the
fourth week of the new school year and
some parents still are trying to sort
out how to get their child to and from
school with the need for more bus
drivers mary jane bliesa explains why
some students need to use an rtc bus
from school buses not showing up to
overcrowding and canceled routes the
school district teamed up with the
regional transportation commission to
provide high school students
transportation it provides teens at
select high schools more independent
reliable and flexible service to and
from school some parents though are
still confused jennifer edward's
daughter just started her freshman year
at basic high school edwards says her
daughter was first taking the school bus
with friends but has since been told she
wasn't eligible for ccsd transportation
since she was enrolled in the rtc right
on program i don't want to send her on a
public bus down boulder highway
by herself when she's barely 14 years
old so i take her to school every day
which makes me late to work
and then
i'm supposed to work till 5 30 at night
but i have to leave at 1
to come get her edwards says verifying
transportation eligibility and roots
have been challenging her friend's bus
who she's been getting on picks up the
housing track across directly across the
street from us drives past our house and
picks up that bus stop but can't pick
her up or she can't get on it at the bus
stop it doesn't make any sense
ultimately edward says she just wants
answers so she knows her daughter can
get to school safely my husband called
ccsd transportation they told him to
call basic basic told him to call
just the school district and the school
district said there was nothing they
could do to help us and that if she gets
caught on the wrong bus like they'll
just
never let her on it again i have reached
out to ccsd who says they are working to
reach out to the edwards to address this
issue mary jane balleza 8 news now